this is something that should have us
all holding out hope until the very very
last minute
that president trump can somehow eke out
an election victory here i don't i still
don't think there's any reason to
concede before the electors vote
we should all be holding out hope
because it's not just joe biden though
he's probably the greatest example of
this
for decades elite politicians in this
country
have sold us out to china they've done
it because they have a stupid political
ideology
that tells them that rising china is
good for the world that's why they let
the china into the world trade
organization 20 years ago it's why
they've allowed china to steal our
intellectual property that's why they've
allowed china
to violate world trade organization
treaties that's why they've allowed
china to illegally subsidize their steel
and aluminum and
manipulate their currency the list goes
on and on and on and on
most importantly they've allowed china
to steal our jobs
and the the argument for it is oh it's
good for the world if china
gets more economic power they'll
liberalize their country they'll become
more democratic they'll become more like
america and that'll be good for
everybody
obviously that hasn't happened the other
reason is that china is just buying
direct influence
you saw this with the hunter biden
scandal you've seen this with other
american politicians we now have
experts on communist china admitting
this kind of influence there was a
recently recorded lecture
showing a chinese communist party expert
explaining
how china has quote people at the top
of america's core inner circle this
video has been leaked made its way
onto the internet and into the united
states after it was
censored in china the person giving this
lecture is dee
dong shing he's vice dean of the school
of international relations at remnin
iren mean university my chinese is not
great but my ability to read subtitles
is take a listen to this
we know that the trump administration is
in a trade wars
things were resolved in no time like a
couple do with their quarrels we fixed
everything in two months
what's the reason i'm going to throw out
something a little explosive here
it's just because we have people at the
top
at the top of america's core inner
circle of power and influence
we have our old friends for the past 30
years 40 years
we've been utilizing the core power of
the united states
we know which people he's talking about
here notably he's talking about
biden who's given speeches about this
he's given speeches about how great it
is
to empower china he's gone on the record
but you've heard all the other kind of
liberal establishment people talking
about this as well this sort of
admission
is so explosive that i didn't believe it
actually this video was going all around
the internet yesterday i didn't believe
it
but mainstream news outlets not many of
them but some of them
are are reporting on this because they
have to because this is real
this this is a real guy he really is the
vice dean of this
ir school and he's really talking about
influence chinese influence in the
united states hostile powers have often
exerted influence in the united states
right now i'm reading witness by
whitaker chambers it's one of the books
that
turned reagan from a liberal into a
conservative it's from an ex-communist
who details in painstaking detail all
of the soviet influence in the united
states during the 30s
during even even a little before that
and during the 40s
guys who were at the very tippy top guys
who were helping to establish the united
nations
guys who were in the state department
guys who were in the justice department
who were communist
spies and they had that soviet union had
that for a long time when people
make fun of mccarthyism where they make
fun of the house on american activities
committee
we all that's like the punch line now
for a lot of people what that fails to
acknowledge is
these guys were right i mean joe
mccarthy was a little bit of a flawed
individual in the way that he carried
these things out no question about it
william f buckley jr founder of national
review wrote one of his first books
defending joe mccarthy because the
central thesis here that the soviet
union had
communist spies at high levels of the
government was obviously true
we know this we know their names we know
the name alger hiss
we know we know people who were
whitaker chambers called this out
mccarthy i suppose called this out nixon
called this out
all made fun of all mocked all have been
sort of written out of the
history of that era but it happened and
it's happening now
with china he goes on
now that we're seeing biden was elected
the traditional elite the political
elite establishment
they're very close to wall street
trump has been saying the biden's son
has some sort
there are a lot of deals in all these
who helped hunter biden build the
foundation who do you think
who do you think china
this this guy points out very astutely
that wall street
used to exert a lot of influence in the
united states
and then after the financial crisis 2007
2008
wall street lost a fair bit of their
influence and they were sort of the bad
guys because they plunged us all into
this global recession
still the establishment was playing
along and then you had trump
and trump comes in and he offered a
radically different
policy at the domestic level but also at
the international level
don't forget from bush one maybe even
further back than bush one but certainly
from bush one clinton
bush ii obama the president's changed
the parties changed but the foreign
policy
more or less stayed the same didn't
change all that much
our attitude toward china didn't change
at all really
it kept getting nicer and nicer and
softer and softer
then trump comes in and he says no what
are you guys doing
people make this mistake they think
trump was elected because
of his personality because he said some
mean things and made fun of mika
brzezinski's face
not so donald trump offered a different
policy agenda then did the other
republicans in the primary and then did
joe hillary clinton and i suppose joe
biden too
it was a different agenda specifically
with regard to our greatest
geo-political foe
this will be coming back if joe biden
becomes
the president okay this is going to
raise a lot of security issues when we
think about national security we're
always talking about the middle east or
you know terrorists coming over here
a far greater security issue will come
from china there is
no reason to play nicely with china
china views us
as an enemy and an adversary and there
is a political elite in the united
states
now led by joe biden that wants to
deny that adversarial relationship got
to keep security on our mind